morgen
ich teile ihnen mit dass der ältestenrat
in seiner gestrigen sitzung der sich
darauf verständigt hat während der
haushaltsberatung vom sechsten bis
neunten september
2022 wie üblich keine befragung der
bundesregierung keine fragestunde und
keine aktuellen stunden durchzuführen
als präsenztage nach § 14 absatz 1 des
abgeordnetengesetzes werden die tage von
montag dem 5 september 2022 bis freitag
den 19 september
2022 festgelegt sind sie damit
einverstanden ich sehe da kein
widerspruch dann verfahren wir so
wir sind weiterhin vor eintritt in die
tagesordnung mir wurde mitgeteilt dass
das wort zur geschäftsordnung gewünscht
wird
frau präsidentin ich möchte einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag stellen und zwar
im namen der fraktion spd fdp grüne
linke und cdu csu wir beantragen die
heutige tagesordnung um die beratung der
beschlussempfehlung des ausschusses für
wahlprüfung immunität geschäftsordnung
zur änderung der geschäftsordnung des
bundestages hier den paragrafen
126 der geschäftsordnung zu erweitern es
geht um die drucksache 2480 das ist der
tagesordnungspunkt der heute morgen
keine mehrheit gefunden hatte und dieser
tagesordnungspunkt zu beantragen wie es
soll nach dem top 27 k vor ohne
aussprache hier aufgesetzt werden
vielen dank wird dazu weiterhin das wort
gewünscht
das ist nicht der fall
damit haben die koalitionsfraktionen
beantragt die heutige tagesordnung um
die beratung der beschlussempfehlung des
ja
bitte
mit cdu csu fraktion und mit der
fraktion die linke diesen antrag
gestellt dann korrigiere ich mich an
dieser stelle
und
beantragt über die fraktion
beschlussempfehlung des ausschusses für
geschäftsordnung wahlprüfung immunität
und geschäftsordnung zur änderung der
geschäftsordnung des deutschen
bundestages hier paragraf 126 der
bundestages zu erweitern es handelt sich
wie gerade erwähnt um die drucksache
2480 diese tagesordnungspunkt soll nach
tagesordnungspunkt 27 ohne aussprache
aufgesetzt worden
gemäß § 20 absatz 2 satz 3 der
geschäftsordnung kann nach eröffnung
einer plenarsitzung eine änderung der
tagesordnung nur beantragt werden wenn
mehr ein entsprechender antrag bis 18
uhr des vortages vorgelegen hat das ist
zugegebenermaßen nicht der fall
bedarf und deshalb bedarf es
diesbezüglich einer abweichung von
unserer geschäftsordnung nach paragraf
hierfür ist eine mehrheit von zwei
dritteln der anwesenden erforderlich wir
kommen nun zur abstimmung über die
abweichung von der geschäftsordnung und
zugleich über die aussetzung der
beantragten beratung wer stimmt für die
beantragte aussetzung der beratung der
beschlussempfehlung des ausschusses für
die wahlprüfung immunität und
geschäftsordnung zur änderung der
geschäftsordnung des deutschen
bundestages
unter verzicht auf die erwähnte
antragsfrist sehe schon ganz viele arme
dafür sind die fraktion die linke spd
bündnis 90 grünen fdp cdu csu fraktion
wer stimmt dagegen das ist die afg
fraktion
gibt es enthaltung das ist nicht der
fall dann ist die beratung der genannten
beschlussempfehlungen mit der
erforderlichen mehrheit als
tagesordnungspunkt aufgesetzt die
beratung erfolgt nach tagesordnungspunkt
ich rufe jetzt auf den zusatzpunkt
23 zweite und dritte beratung des von
den fraktionen der spd cdu/csu bündnis
90/die grünen und fdp eingebrachten
gesetzentwurfs zu den protokollen zum
nordatlantik vertrag über den beitritt
der republik finnland und des
königsreichs schweben
für die aussprache wurde eine dauer von
68 minuten beschlossen
doch dann probiert
liebe kolleginnen kollegen unsere
beratung zu diesem tag
tagesordnungspunkt verfolgen auf der
ehrentribüne die botschafterin der
republik finnland ihre exzellenz frau
anna sie planen und die gesandte des
königsreichs schweden frau jenny sendung
mein christsein sie uns herzlich
willkommen
jetzt eröffnet die aussprache und das
wort hat zuerst der staatsminister dr
tobias lindner für die bundesregierung
frau präsidentin exzellenzen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen mit dem
gebrauch des begriffs historisch sollten
vorsichtig sein er nutzt sich schnell ab
aber ich in die bundesregierung das sind
fest davon überzeugt dass dies zu recht
ein
historischer moment ist die geplanten
beiträge finnlands und schwedens zum
nordatlantischen verteidigungsbündnisses
von herausragender bedeutung für uns und
unsere partner
angesichts der erschütterungen den wir
aufgrund des russischen angriffskrieges
gegen die ukraine in europa in der
ganzen welt erfahren wollen wir als
enger verbündeter füreinander einstehen
die bundesregierung unterstützt
finnland und schweden ausdrücklich auf
ihrem weg in die nato und einer sich
dramatisch veränderten sicherheitslage
in europa bedeutet dieser beitritt nicht
nur für unsere nordischen partner
zusätzliche sicherheit sondern auch für
unser bündnis in gänze ein zugewinn an
stärke und zusammenhalt denn mit
schweden und finnland verbindet uns
schon lange eine enge und
vertrauensvolle partnerschaft und
freundschaft
getragen von gemeinsamen werten und
interessen wie sie sich auch eine
mitgliedschaft in der europäischen union
zeigen wir stärken heute die
demokratische mitte der nato
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das sind
davon überzeugt dass die sicherheit im
gesamten euro atlantischen raum durch
sie gestärkt werden mit ihnen gewinnen
wir 2 fähiger leistungsstarke und
verlässliche verbündete die
verteidigungsfähigkeit unserer allianz
zusätzlich stärken werden insbesondere
für die verteidigung des ostseeraums und
der nordflanke der allianz ist das eine
elementare stärkung und beide länder
sind schon ganz besonders enge
kooperation der nato gewesen als solche
haben finnland schweden den letzten
jahren gemeinsam einsetzen und manövern
teilgenommen die militärische
interoperabilität mit der nato ist
bereits jetzt gegeben und dass sie nun
heute diesen historischen schritt tun
was sie ihre neutralität hinter sich
lassen und sich der nato anschließen ja
das ist auch ein vertrauensbeweis für
die allianz und ihre mitglieder sie
wollen ihr schicksal nur noch enger mit
dem unseren verbinden und dieses
vertrauen dass wir uns entgegenbringen
zeigt die stärke der nato als
verteidigungsbündnis
freier demokratischer staat
aber
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
historisch ist auch das voranschreiten
des beitrittsprozesses die
bundesregierung hat sich von von beginn
an für einen möglichst schnellen
beitritt ausgesprochen
nach dem fehlenden stehen am 18 mai
beitritts anträge gestellt haben konnten
bereits am vergangenen dienstagmorgen
die beitritts protokolle durch alle 30
nato staaten unterzeichnet werden unser
dank gilt hier insbesondere
nato-generalsekretär jens stoltenberg
dessen zielgerichtete und feinfühlige
führung der notwendigen gespräche eine
ganz wesentliche grundlage für die
zustimmung aller 30 alliierten war
nun
müssen die beitritts protokolle von
allen nato staaten ratifiziert werden
die bundesrepublik deutschland hat schon
jetzt mit der heutigen zügigen
beratungen abstimmung durch die
verfassungsorgane zuerst hier im
deutschen bundestag später im bundesrat
und wichtiges signal des beistands und
unterstützung gesendet nach der
öffentlichen zustimmung wird der
bundespräsident die ratifikationsurkunde
ausfertigen wir werden sie in washington
oder nordatlantik vertrag hinterlegt ist
verfahren deutschland gehört damit zu
der ersten gruppe von staaten die die
ratifikation der beitritt protokolle
prinzip
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich möchte ihnen an dieser stelle
hierfür im namen der bundesregierung
recht herzlich danken das ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit in drei tagen
eine ratifikation vorzunehmen lassen sie
uns lassen sie deutschland verlässliche
verbündete und gute partner von finnland
schweden sein wenn es um unsere
militärischen zu sagen geht genauso wie
die stärkung des demokratischen
fundaments der nordatlantischen allianz
und beides bietet für heute vielen dank
der staatsminister im auswärtigen amt
tobias lindner hat sich noch mal
gedanken in der tat hat der bundestag
wirklich gas gegeben am mittwoch die
erste lesung heute die zweite dritte
lesung und heute mittag bereits dann die
verabschiedung im bundesrat damit dürfte
deutschland der erste nato staat sein
der die den beitritt der beiden länder
finnland und schweden ratifiziert hat
jetzt david wedepohl johann david gerade
prüft die union
so ein gesetz beschließen das wir
exzellenzen
zustimmen dass finnland republik
finnland und das königreich schweden der
nato beitreten dass wir dies tun liegt
in der sehr ernsten
sicherheitspolitischen lage begründet an
russlands aggression und gewalt an der
bedrohung die russland unverblümt für
europa darstellt aber dass wir es tun
ist zugleich ein grund der freude denn
mit finnland und schweden heißen wir
zwei ohnehin schon eng befreundete
staaten unserer gemeinschaft willkommen
das ist ein wichtiges signal an russland
dass wir es nicht dulden dass zwei
ostsee partner bedrängt bedroht und
erpresst werden wir treten für den
schutz unserer partner ein und nehmen
sie deswegen als bündnispartner in
unserer schutz bündnis auf wie groß
dieser wunsch nach schutz ist zeigt ein
blick in die geschichtsbücher finnland
was war seit 1945 neutral es ist in
schwierigsten zeiten des kalten krieges
im durchaus bedrohten schatten der
sowjetunion stolz und wehrhaft seinen
weg gegangen und es hat nach dem ende
des kalten krieges keine veranlassung
gesehen diesen weg zu verlassen
doch putins unverhohlenen militärischen
und politischen drohungen gegenüber
seinen westlichen nachbarstaaten sein
missbrauch der geschichte um geografisch
weit ausgreifende imperiale ansprüche
eines neuen russischen reiches zu
formulieren vor allem aber seine
eklatante missachtung
staatlicher souveränität in dem er
anderen staaten der ukraine aber auch
finnland das recht abspricht selbst über
die bündnismitglieder zu entscheiden das
hat in finnland seit jahren immer mehr
ein missbehagen ausgelöst und eine
stetig wachsende zuwendung zur nato der
russische angriffe auf die ukraine gab
schließlich den ausschlag
in schweden an die gleichen sorgen eine
phase der 200-jährigen neutralität
beendet letztmalig war schweden 1814 in
einem bündnis nichts macht so deutlich
als diese für schweden und finnland so
unglaubliche zäsur ihrer außen- und
sicherheitspolitik mit dem nato-beitritt
finnlands und schwedens ist putins neo
imperiale politik die letztendlich auf
eine russische dominanz über ost und
mittelosteuropa und weite teile des
ostseeraums hinauslief krachend
gescheitert aber der beitritt finnlands
und schwedens weist über die region und
über den sachverhalt
hinaus denn er ist was er ist ein
beitritt und keine erweiterung es ist
der souveräne wunsch finnlands und
schwedens teil der nato zu werden
getragen von einer absolut
überwältigenden mehrheit der jeweiligen
parteien und menschen in den staaten und
das zeigt wie attraktiv die nato ist
quicklebendig
nach über 70 jahren nicht hirntod
existenziell für die sicherheit des
westens nicht obsolet und deswegen ist
es ein folge richtiges und wichtiges
zeichen dass die bundesregierung
frühzeitig und dafür möchte ich den
bundeskanzler danken die jeweiligen
ministerpräsidentinnen auch eingeladen
hatte hier nach deutschland und die
weichen dafür gestellt dass deutschland
zu den ersten
anwältinnen des beitrittes dieser beiden
staaten gehört an der stelle auch für
die cdu/csu-fraktion ein dank dafür dass
die bundesregierung an dieser stelle
impulsgeber gewesen ist
verbindet das mit der genugtuung darüber
dass manche in den rhein insbesondere
der sozialdemokraten und der grünen die
zweifel hegten an der bedeutung und
wichtigkeit der nato dass diese zweifel
jetzt zerstreut sind und dass wir jetzt
alle 100 prozent die anhänger dieses
wichtigen verteidigungsbündnisses des
westens sind
und ich verbinde ist mit der bitte und
erwartung dass die bundesregierung auch
für den weiteren beitrittsprozess als
anwalt finnlands und schwedens star
steht bedingungen aus der türkei die den
rechtsstaats maßstab dieser beiden
staaten relativierten oder die sie gar
dazu aufforderten die menschenrechts
konvention des europarates zu verletzen
während nicht akzeptabel der stelle muss
deutschland klar an der seite dieser
beiden staaten stehen wie diese mit
asylanten und flüchtlingen umgehen ist
deren souveräne entscheidung und darf
auf keinen fall eine bedingung für die
aufnahme in der nato sein
diese beiden staaten werden die nase
stärken sie sind ein echter gewinn für
das bündnis sie bringen streitkräfte in
die verlangte des bündnisses die
erfahrenen modern und schlagkräftig sind
sie geben der verteidigung und
abschreckung an der ostflanke des
bündnisses mehr tiefe stärke und
glaubwürdigkeit davon profitiert auch
deutschland und der beitritt sendet ein
zeichen an präsident putin hat das
erreicht was er immer macht
verhindern wollte er hat den westen er
hat die nato auch der 1 er hat die nato
so stark gemacht so attraktiv wie sie
seit das ende des kalten krieges nicht
mehr wahr er ist damit als neuer tag
gescheitert der ostseeraum und dessen
rand ich selber in deutschland lebe ist
steht geschlossen gegen diese ambitionen
putins er ist zu einem raum von staaten
geworden die den demokratischen die
demokratischen werte teilen die sich
zusammengeschlossen haben um diese werte
und ihre gesellschaften zu schützen
deswegen es ist ein grund zur freude zum
feiern willkommen finnland willkommen
schweden wir bekräftigen hier und heute
wir stehen an eurer seite und wir sind
stolz dass ihr auch zukünftig an unserer
seite stehen wird vielen dank
ein klares bekenntnis nicht weiter
überraschen von johann david wadephul
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion die diesen antrag zur
aufnahme von finnland und schweden
gemeinsam mit den ampel fraktionen und
mit der bundesregierung hier im
deutschen bundestag eingebracht haben
jetzt die verteilung ist
exzellenten exzellenzen meine damen und
herren finnland und schweden haben sich
entschieden der nato beizutreten und wir
erleben die europäische geschichte
geschrieben wird beide länder geben
dadurch jahrhundertealte traditionen auf
in beiden ländern war die neutralität
staatsraison und stolze diplomatische
praxis getragen nicht nur von einer
politischen entscheidung sondern auch
von einem lebensgefühl über lange zeit
waren finden und schweden überzeugt dass
gerade die neutralität ihre sicherheit
garantieren würde und von so einer
grundsätzlichen überzeugung
verabschiedet man sich nur dann wenn
etwas wirklich einschneidendes geschehen
ist und der brutale angriffskrieg putins
auch die ukraine ist ein solches
einschneidendes ereignis
heute ist der 135 tag des krieges seit
viereinhalb monaten sehen wir alle wie
zerbrechlich die freiheit in europa ist
und dass wir sicherheit auf unserem
kontinent neu denken müssen viele
menschen haben umgedacht hier bei uns
und auch die große mehrheit der finnen
und schweden sie sind heute überzeugt
dass sie für ihre sicherheit verbündete
brauchen der beschluss den wir heute
fassen wollen ist ein ergebnis dieser
viereinhalb monate krieg vor allem aber
eine deutliche absage an diesen krieg
meine damen und herren
mit dieser erweiterung mit dieser
erweiterung unserer allianz stärken wir
genau die sicherheitsarchitektur genau
die friedensordnung die putin zerstören
will er erreicht nun das gegenteil von
dem was er sich erhofft hatte die
demokraten werden wehrhafter sie rücken
zusammen der westen den er so verachtet
wird stärker nicht schwächer
der schritt finnlands und schwedens ist
deshalb wichtig und trick und der ist
richtig und der verdient unsere volle
unterstützung
und ich freue mich deswegen sehr dass
deutschland mit dem beschluss des
bundestages heute so schnell seine
zustimmung zur aufnahme unserer
schwedischen und finnischen freunde
erteilt und dass diese zustimmung von
einer so großen mehrheit der
abgeordneten unseres parlaments getragen
wird deutschland sendet damit ein
wichtiges zeichen der solidarität und
der verlässlichkeit
in die nato die nato beginnt an der nord
und ost flanke entscheidend an stärke
das macht alle nato-staaten sichere
beide finnland und schweden verfügen
über leistungsfähige streitkräfte modern
ausgerüstet und erprobt in vielen uno
friedenseinsätze mit staaten
seestreitkräften die vor allem die
ostsee sicherer machen und mit modernen
und schnell aufwuchs fähigen
landstreitkräften die die bedrohte
ostgrenze sehr gut kennen mit einem
breiten gesellschaftlichen
verständnis von sicherheit und
wehrhaftigkeit von vorsorgereserven und
bereitschaft von dem wir uns einiges
abschauen könnten und mit kameradinnen
und kameraden die seit vielen jahren eng
mit der nato kooperieren und schon
längst zu unseren vertrauten geworden
sind der europäische fuß der nato wird
durch diesen beitritt noch größer und
davon profitieren auch unsere
nordamerikanischen
bündnispartner denn wenn die europäer in
bündnis an fähigkeiten hinzu gewinnen
dann ist das gut für die faire
lastenverteilung europas kraft wird
größer und die usa werden entlastet und
auch für die europäische union ist dies
eine wichtige eine gute entscheidung
zwei weitere eu staaten werden nun in
der nato seien insgesamt gehören dann 23
von 27
mitgliedern dem bündnis an und beide
organisationen rücken so enger zusammen
die chancen zur intensiven
zusammenarbeit werden dadurch noch
einmal ein ganzes stück größer
meine damen und herren unsere
atlantische allianz zeigt mit diesem
beitritt dass sie handlungsfähig ist
noch vor kurzem wurde behauptet nato
seit ihrem tod es war ein irrtum es ist
gerade die stärke der nato dass man
wenig von ihr hört und dass sie nicht
dominant auftritt wenn sie nicht so sehr
im fokus steht dass sie aber genau dann
da ist wenn sie gebraucht wird so wie
jetzt schon seit 2014 seit der
völkerrechtswidrigen annexion der krim
durch putins russland steuert die nato
um die verstärkung der ostflanke an der
deutschland führend beteiligt ist zeigt
dies deutlich deutlich vor allem aber
jetzt im akuten kriegsfall in europa
zeigen europäer und nordamerikaner im
bündnis wie ernst es ihnen mit der
sicherheit ist die weitere verstärkung
unserer abschreckungs und
verteidigungsfähigkeit an der ostgrenze
der nato ist beschlossen und wird
bereits umgesetzt
präsident biden hat das zweite mal nach
seiner amtsübernahme eine aufstockung
der amerikanischen truppen präsenz in
europa beschlossen und damit amerikas
verpflichtung gegenüber europa sehr
deutlich bekräftigt und nach jahrzehnten
des sparens und des abbaus steigen die
verteidigungsausgaben der bündnispartner
wieder und deutschland leistet hier mit
dem sonderfall von 100 milliarden euro
für die bundeswehr einen ganz wichtigen
beitrag
in der vergangenen woche
in der vergangenen woche haben die 30
nato mitgliedsstaat und ihrem bündnis
ein neues strategisches konzept gegeben
ein fahrplan für die transatlantische
sicherheit der auf die russische
bedrohung reagiert und der auch die
risiken und herausforderungen der
zukunft im blick hat und die nato blickt
in die welt jenseits europas und
nordamerikas unserer partnerschaften mit
anderen freiheitlichen demokratien
werden deutlich ausgeweitet zum beispiel
mit japan australien und südkorea auch
weil es diese staaten selbst sind die
die nähe so nato suchen der beitritt
finnland und schweden muss auch in
diesem weiten kontext gesehen werden er
gehört zu einem bündnis im aufbruch das
sich fit macht um auch in zukunft der
entscheidende garant für sicherheit zu
sein für sicherheit die dann noch etwas
anderes bedeutet als nur klassische
harter sicherheit die den vernetzten
ansatz aufnimmt sich also auch mit
energie und entwicklung mit
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen fragen
beschäftigt die auch die daten welten im
cyberspace ausgerichtet ist die auch den
weltraum fest im blick hat denn ohne
satelliten ist heute keine kommunikation
und nach keine navigation mehr denkbar
eine zeitenwende also nicht nur in
deutschland sondern auch für die nato
insgesamt und für unsere gemeinsame
sicherheit mit der aufnahme finnlands
und schwedens in die nato-staaten wir
freiheit und demokratie wir machen das
recht und die offenen gesellschaften
wehrhafte wir festigen die europäische
und transatlantische solidarität und
senden eine sehr deutliche botschaft an
diejenigen die all das zerstören wollen
ich sage ihnen protein gelingt diese
zerstörung nicht er hatte auf unsere
schwäche gesetzt jetzt bekommt er das
gegenteil der historische schritt von
finnland und schweden stärkten nato und
damit uns alle vielen dank
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht in ihren schlussworten hat sie
es noch einmal zusammengefasst
die beiden weitere zwillingen länder
stärken die nato werden aber nicht auf
die idee gekommen eine nato
mitgliedschaft zu beantragen wenn es
nicht diesen angriffskrieg gegeben hätte
durch die russen und jetzt hier
alexander gauland als nächster redner
für die afg
exzellenzen meine damen und herren
um es gleich an den anfang zu stellen
auch wir akzeptieren den grünen
schwedens und finnlands der nato
beizutreten
wenn wir dies nicht mit überschäumender
freude und begeisterung tun dann hat das
nichts mit den beiden demokratischen
kandidaten sondern ausschließlich mit
den umständen und dem zeitpunkt dieses
schritts zu tun
in einer geopolitischen
auseinandersetzung die zu einem krieg in
europa geführt hat können gleich
gewichtsverschiebungen auch wenn sie
erst einmal symbolischen charakter haben
konflikte verschärfen statt sie zu
entspannen
wir halten es deshalb für wichtig dass
besonders viel land mit seiner langen
land grenze zu russland auch in der nato
weiter seine traditionelle rolle als
übersetzung russische befindlichkeiten
und wünsche spielt wie es das
erfolgreich oder dem früheren
präsidenten kennen viele jahre getan hat
und wir gehen weiter davon aus dass auch
künftig keine nato truppen und auch
keine atomwaffen dauerhaft auf dem
territorium beider länder stationiert
werden
das ist im interesse des friedens note
wenn der beitritt dazu führt dass das
europäische gewicht künftig stärker die
politik der nato bestimmt als die ganz
anders gelagerten und europäischen
wünschen oft widerstreitenden
geostrategischen interessen der usa
wäre das sogar ein zusätzlicher
positiver effekt
allerdings muss ich anmerken dass die
menschenrechtlichen rabatte in der
trilateralen
absichtserklärung zu gunsten der türkei
mehr als nur ein wermutstropfen für eine
wertegemeinschaft sind als die sicher
die nato versteht weil damen und herren
wir haben in der vergangenheit die
ausdehnung der nato gegen die russischen
grenzen die von russland innerlich nie
akzeptiert wurde als eine der ursachen
für die krisenhafte zuspitzung
unseres verhältnisses zu russland
ausgemacht diese einschätzung bleibt
nach wie vor richtig
allerdings sehen wir auch dass bei der
berufung auf peter den grossen durch den
russischen präsidenten mit dem wir unter
anderem auch den ukraine krieg
rechtfertigt
gegner von peters damaliger expansion
also besonders schweden neue
sicherheiten und verbündeten zu
das historische gedächtnis in schweden
und finnland ist lang und es bewahrt
leider keine erinnerungen an ungetrübte
freundschaft mit dem großen nachbarn
gerade wenn wir geschichte als
lehrmeisterin für gegenwart und zukunft
ernst nehmen
müssen wir den wunsch finnlands und
schwedens nach größerer sicherheit
akzeptieren
ihre entscheidung und unsere positive
antwort ist realpolitik im besten sinne
zum jubel besteht kein anlass meine
damen und herren zu einem
realpolitischen willkommen schon ich
bedanke mich
der bundestag diskutiert den
gesetzentwurf des nato beitritts von
finnland und schweden bedeuten ferati fi
kation in zweiter dritter lesung und der
nächste redner kommt von der fdp
fraktion der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
alexander graf lambsdorff
meine damen und herren staatsminister
linde hat es eben gesagt man muss mit
dem wort historisch vorsichtig umgehen
aber ich glaube wir sind uns alle einig
der nato gipfel von madrid mit seiner
einladung zur aufnahme ins bündnis an
schweden und finnland das war ein
historischer gipfel der abschied
finnlands und schwedens von der
traditionellen neutralitätspolitik ist
ein so dramatischer wendepunkt in der
geschichte beider länder dass ich am
anfang meiner ausführung das nochmal
illustrieren will was das eigentlich
bedeutet
finnland wurde von hitler und ribbentrop
sowie die baltischen staaten auch der
sowjetunion zur eroberung freigegeben
finnland musste seine unabhängigkeit in
einem blutigen winterkrieg 39 40
behaupten 70.000 menschen haben ihre
gesundheit oder ihr leben dort verloren
und nach dem zweiten weltkrieg wurde
finnland in eine neutralität gezwungen
die es aber dann angenommen gefüllt und
gelebt hat und es hat sie nach dem
untergang der sowjetunion 1991
fortgesetzt weil zu diesem zeitpunkt in
den 90er jahren keine notwendigkeit zur
aufgabe der neutralität war es war eine
zeit in der russland keine gefahr
darstellte aber diese zeit meine damen
und herren die ist vorbei dass russland
keine gefahr für die republik finnland
werden würde dass es spätestens seit
februar dieses jahres in finnland
politischer konsens es ist ein
historischer und geopolitischer kaum zu
überschätzender kurswechsel unseres
befreundeten landes finnland
und noch weitreichender
jedenfalls chronologisch ist die
entscheidung schwedens das seit 1818
für sich neutralität angenommen hat
könig karl johann erhob das prinzip der
neutralität zur wichtigsten
außenpolitischen strategie seit dieser
zeit verstand sich das land als neutral
und wurde auch so wahrgenommen eine
insel der rechtschaffenden in einer
heillos kriegerischen welt neutralität
demokratie eine eigene außen und
sicherheitspolitik verliehen dem land
sogar während der zwei weltkriege eine
vergleichsweise ausgeprägte stabilität
und bis vor wenigen wochen waren sich
alle regierungen in schweden einig die
allianz freie hat der welt und im land
gut gedient doch nach dem angriff
russlands auf die ukraine nach
unzähligen für russischen verletzungen
des schwedischen luft und seeraumes da
verkündet nun auf schweden ein
gemeinsamer schwedische und finnische
nato beitritt würde die lage in europa
stabilisieren meine damen und herren
dieses parlament sagte diese
einschätzung deutlich ja heute das ist
historisch
zwei gefestigte demokratien beide völlig
unverdächtig irgendwelcher
militaristischer attitüden beide stehen
sie seit langem bündnis politisch
ungebunden und suchen jetzt zuflucht
unter dem sicherheitsschirm des
westlichen verteidigungsbündnisses
natürlich gibt es dann auch hier die
legendenbildung im haus und draußen wir
haben es gerade gehört es sei ja nur ein
geopolitischer konflikt der zum krieg
geführt hat nein meine damen und herren
das war kein geopolitischer konflikt in
dem alle akteure gleich zu bewerten sind
das narrativ
eines geopolitischen konflikts in dem
alle gleich zu bewerten sind das
narrativ des bedrängten russlands sollen
ja eigentlich nur die unterstützung der
menschen die dieses negativ verbreiten
für eine russische außenpolitik die
expansionistische revisionistisch und ja
auch
gewalttätig ist
wenn wir hier gerade gehört haben dass
wladimir putin sich auch peter den
grossen bezieht peter den ersten dann
ist denjenigen die sich ein wenig mit
der geschichte der russischen monarchie
auskennen eines klar diese vergleich
könnte falscher nicht sein wenn man
schon einen zarten bemühen wollte
helgoland dann wäre es nikolaus der
erste er hat die geheimpolizei gegründet
er hat nach innen brutale repression
ausgeübt und hat am ende seines lebens
im krimkrieg verloren ich glaube das ist
eine bessere analogie als peter der erst
deswegen meine damen und herren
ignorieren wir dieses narrativ der
nato-beitritt finnlands und schwedens
worden nicht auf einer angeblichen
bedrohung russlands auf er ist die
fortsetzung einer klaren und einigen
politik des westens die sich für eine
politik der sicherheit und stabilität im
euro atlantischen raum einsetzt und hier
will ich eines hinzufügen als
vorsitzender der deutsch britischen
parlamentariergruppe
die sicherheit im ostseeraum sie wird
durch den beitritt der beiden länder
enorm ansteigen die distanz von helsinki
nach tallinn über den finnischen
meerbusen sind keine 90 kilometer dieser
fortsatz des bündnis ist er so schwer zu
verteidigen da der drei baltischen
republiken wird jetzt teil des nato
gebiets auf eine art und weise
abzusichern wie es vorher nicht möglich
war das ist ein ganz konkreter
fortschritt für unsere freunde auch im
baltikum meine damen und herren
meine damen und herren die
verteidigungsministerin hat es gesagt
die nato ist unser gemeinsamer
schutzbund wir bauen auf abschreckung
innenverteidigung krisenprävention und
krisenbewältigung und ja wo immer
möglich bauen wir auf kooperative
sicherheit wir stellen uns gemeinsam
gegen die aggression russlands zu dieser
zeit ich bin überzeugt dass damit die
sicherheit im gesamten euro atlantischen
raum gestärkt wird dass wir mit finnland
und schweden zwei fähige verbündete
gewinnen und wir werden unser
verteidigungsbündnis so nachhaltig
stärken herzlichen dank
auch alexander graf lambsdorff und die
fdp also rückhaltlos für den beitritt
von finnland und schweden auf das keine
überraschung bei dem nächsten redner
sieht das ganz anders aus gregor gysi
von der linken traditionell ja sehr
russlandfreundlich ist aber gegen den
beitritt aus einem ganz anderen grund
und das wären wir sicherlich gleich hier
hören
ich bin noch hier meine redezeit nicht
ihre fragen zu beantworten aber mal
abgesehen davon sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin exzellenzen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
finnland und schweden sind nord
europäische staaten haben ähnlichkeiten
aber auch eine unterschiedliche
geschichte finnland gehört zum
russischen zarenreich linie gab es frei
stalin führte einen krieg gegen finnland
und holt es zurück nun ist es aber seit
jahrzehnten unabhängig es gibt eine
lange grenze finnland russland und eine
lange gemeinsame und getrennte
geschichte beider länder finnland sieht
wie auch schweden gefahren durch
russland die linke stand und steht
kritisch zur nato ich erinnere an den
völkerrechtswidrigen krieg der nato
gegen serbien an den falschen krieg der
nato gegen afghanistan bei der
führungsmacht in der nato den usa
erinnere ich an deren
völkerrechtswidrige kriege gegen werden
und den irak schweden und finnland haben
in den vergangenen jahrzehnten als
militärisch neutrale staaten viel
geleistet ich erinnere an die konferenz
von helsinki ich erinnere an das wirken
von ministerpräsident olof palme und
viele andere aber russland hat
völkerrechtswidrig die ukraine
angegriffen deshalb müssen wir ein
solches
sicherheitsbedürfnis respektiert so
wollte ich meiner fraktion empfehlen
den nato-beitritt schwedens und
finnlands nicht abzulehnen sondern sich
zu enthalten aber nun gibt es eine
trilaterale absichtserklärung der türkei
finnland und schweden finnland und
schweden werden danach die uwg nicht
mehr unterstützen die uwg der kurdinnen
und kurden aber hat den entscheidenden
boden kampf gegen die nun wirklich
terroristischen islamischen staat in
syrien geführt und im irak die
siedlungen und die sieben vor dessen
mörder wandlungen geschützt wir haben
der bg also viel zu verdanken und was
bedeutet eigentlich keine unterstützung
kein geld keine büros kein asyl
vielleicht verbots von arbeitsverträgen
man will auch vermehrt waffen an die
türkei liefern aber diese führt
völkerrechtswidrige kriege gegen die
autonomen gebiete der kurdinnen und
kurden in syrien und im irak was geht es
die türkei endlich an dass es in syrien
und im irak autonome gebiete der kugeln
und komik und nicht zu vergessen sind
die zwischen provokation der partei
gegen das nato mitglied griechenland
gegen zypern und über aserbaidschan auch
gegen armenien r behandelt noch dreister
werden nach seinem erfolg außerdem soll
nun verstärkt aus finnland und schweden
auch menschen in die türkei ausgeliefert
werden der begriff des terrorismus wird
in der türkei völlig anders
interpretiert als in anderen staaten
auch bei uns die nächste nötigung steht
bevor denn erdogan droht indirekt den
beitritt nicht zu ratifizieren wenn die
73 angeblich terrorverdächtigen aus
finnland und schweden nicht an die
türkei ausgeliefert werden der preis den
schweden finnland und die gesamte nato
für den beitritt gegen die kurden und
kurden an die türkei zahlen müssen ist
zu hoch
deshalb habe ich bei einer fraktion
beraten doch mit nein zu stimmen und ich
weiß dass auch andere abgeordnete dies
alles kritisch sehen aber die
fraktionsdisziplin trotzdem ist die
argumentation der anderen fraktion
interessant wenn durch den nato beitritt
die sicherheit finnlands und schwedens
gravierend erhöht wird weil ein angriff
russlands den bündnisfall und damit den
dritten weltkrieg auslöste was auch
putin und russland nicht wollen warum
begründen dann eigentlich die
regierungsfraktionen und die union ihre
gigantischen auf rüstungs beschlüsse mit
einem möglichen angriff russlands auf
deutschland deutschland ist in der nato
und damit doch nach dieser logik sicher
die ausrüstung ist falsch und teile der
sanktionen gegen die russische
bevölkerung sind auch falsch weil sie zu
einer gigantischen verteuerung und
verknappung von lebensmitteln und
energie führen und noch mehr führen
werden
gregor gysi hat begründet warum die
linke heute gegen den nato beitritt
finnlands und schwedens
votieren wird in der tat weiß keiner so
ganz genau was in dem memorandum
festgehalten ist das zwischen finnland
schweden und der türkei getroffen wurde
die türkin jedenfalls machen mächtig
druck auf die beiden weiteren zügigen
länder und nur wenn die türkei am
schluss auch den weiteren trend finnland
und schweden zustimmen wird dann werden
sie mitglieder leben können agniezka
bürger für die bündnisgrünen
von dieser bundes konter gleich noch
dazu kann nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen
dass man dieser bundestagsdebatte die
klare botschaft an unsere freundinnen in
finnland und in schweden ausgeht dass
sie sowas von herzlich willkommen sind
in unserem verteidigungsbündnis
und das ist ein starkes zeichen
englischen schäden hat der
geschlossenheit und der solidarität hier
im bundestag aber auch des bündnisses
ist und ja es ist ein großer gewinn für
die euro atlantische sicherheit das
aushängen altbewährten eu partnern nun
neue noch engere nato verbündete werden
und das nicht allein weil es militärisch
sehr viel gestalten sind die einen
wertvollen und hochwertigen beitrag zum
schutz unseres gemeinsamen
bundesgebietes leisten werden sondern
und da sollte die linke vielleicht zu
viel finnland und schweden sind zwei
staaten die eine starke stimme in der
welt sind für handlungsfähige diplomatie
für rüstungskontrolle für zivile
konfliktbearbeitung für eine
feministische außenpolitik und wenn ich
in das neue strategische konzept der
nato schaue dann finde ich gut dass die
nato sich hier auch weiterentwickeln
wird und auch die lage wird von den
beiträgen zu den platz und schweden mehr
als profitiert
und jetzt komme ich zu ihrer anderen
krieg meine damen und herren es ist in
der tat ich glaube für alle schwer
erträglich dass präsident erdogan das
einstimmigkeitsprinzip in der nato
wirklich brutal für seine eigenen
interessen ausnutzen wollte ich kann
aber allen ihre kolleginnen und kollegen
nur raten den sehr klug formulierten
text zwischen finnland schweden und der
türkei wirklich einmal anzuschauen und
ich kann nicht verstehen ich verstehe
dass sie immer aus prinzip kritisch mit
uns sein wollen aber sie sind doch
normalerweise immer noch kritischer mit
präsident gern warum sie jetzt ein
geschäft betreiben und sich seine
interpretationen dieser in seinem
wahlkampf braucht dieses textes zu eigen
machen das versteht wirklich niemand
und vor allem glauben sie denn dass es
für präsident erdogan leichter oder
schwerer wird um der nato in finnland
und schweden die demokratie und die
rechtsstaatlichkeit und auch die
kritischen kurs gegenüber der türkei
unterstützen werden also vielleicht
wollten sie diesmal noch mal sich eine
chance
meine damen und herren auch hier
wohnhauses auch in vielen debatten in
den letzten jahren haben wir immer
wieder dieses narrativ gehört von dem
namen herr putin der umzingelt wurde von
der nato osterweiterung der in seiner
sicherheit bedroht ist schauen wir uns
noch einmal an was seit dem 24 februar
passiert ist dieser krieg hat dazu
geführt das ist harte
wirtschaftssanktionen gibt die die
russische wirtschaft empfindlich treffen
dass russland außenpolitisch ins stark
isoliert ist durch viele staaten dass
wir an der nato ostflanke deutlich mehr
truppen stationieren werden und dass
jetzt zwei neue staaten der nato
beitreten und eine neue über 1000
kilometer lange grenze wirklich direkt
bei russland entsteht und das zeigt auch
wie wenig er bereit ist zu verhandeln
dass er zahlreiche tausende russische
soldaten verheizt und das eben seine
sicherheits und treffen die
sicherheitsinteressen seines landes die
angeblich so wichtig war für seine
imperialistische
menschenverachtende ideologie opfert und
erst recht wissen wir uns deshalb jeden
tag fragen was wir noch mehr tun können
um die menschen in der ukraine zu
unterstützen
und meine damen und herren
ja man kann feststellen dieser wichtige
schritt finnland und schweden
nach sehr sehr langer zeit und auch
einer kultur der neutralität der ist
sicherlich auch ein ausdruck von sorge
um die eigene sicherheit
es steht eben aber auch dafür dass wenn
kriegsverbrechen schlimmsten ausmaßes
begangen werden tag für tag
menschenrechte skrupellos verletzt
werden wenn die schweizer recht brutal
gebrochen wird internationale
kooperation und friedensordnung
attackiert werden dass unsere freundin
in skandinavien eben nicht neutral
bleiben sondern dass wir gemeinsam mit
ihnen im bündnis in der eu partei
ergreifen für die unschuldigen menschen
in der ukraine für frieden sicherheit
und menschenrechte und deshalb bin ich
sehr dankbar und sehr froh dass heute
auf diesem weg in dieser debatte ein
solches zeichen der geschlossenheit der
entschlossenheit und der klaren
wertevorstellungen ausgeht
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
jürgen hand
jung hat ist der außenpolitische
sprecher der cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
will kolleginnen und kollegen ich freue
mich sehr dass die exzellenzen heute
hier auch auf der besuchertribüne statt
platz genommen haben ich gratuliere
michael roth das andere die auch im
auswärtigen ausschuss dafür gesorgt
haben dass wir unsere beratung in
anwesenheit der botschafterinnen und der
gesamten vollziehen konnten sie hätten
für fragen zur verfügung gestanden aber
wir hatten keine fragen wollten frage
der aufnahme schwedens und finnlands den
wunsch positiv zu entsprechen für die
breite mehrheit hier im haus so
offensichtlich und so eindeutig sind
dass sie auch sicher sein können heute
in ihre hauptstädte zu kabeln bundestag
heute vormittag bundesrat heute mittag
stimmen zu und deutschland ist eines der
ersten länder die den beitritt
ratifiziert und darauf können wir stolz
sein
was muss passiert sein dass er land wie
schweden das 1814 da habe ich das letzte
mal krieg geführt hat und seit über 200
jahren neutrales und an land wie
finnland das trotz der bitteren
erfahrungen im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
über fast acht jahrzehnte sein und
neutralität gewahrt hat dass die jetzt
zur entscheidung kommen die völker
dieser länder zur entscheidung kommen so
nato beitreten zu wollen es ist die
zeitenwende die putin durch seinen
brutalen völkerrechtswidrigen angriff
gegen die ukraine ausgelöst hat der die
welt unsere sicht auf den frieden in
europa leider auf dramatische weise
verändert hat und deswegen ist das ein
guter schritt und ein wichtiger schritt
für uns alle der im übrigen und als eu
in der ja sowieso auch eine
beistandsverpflichtung innerhalb des eu
vertrages haben nur dankbar sein kann
dass jetzt die nato auch ihre schwingen
ausbreitet überschrieben und findet was
den militärischen schutz angeht
es ist hier von
hobby historikern unterschiedlichster
qualität die geschichte bemüht worden
und es ist vor allem verbreitet worden
dass nachher tief putins die nato sein
irgendeiner weise eine bedrohung für
russland
wenn es so wäre dass die nato eine
bedrohung für russland darstellen würde
würde putin wohl kaum einen großen teil
seiner streitkräfte in diesem brutalen
abnutzungskrieg gegen die ukraine
stecken morgen menschen morgens und
material worden dann würden seine
generale ihm sagen du kannst dich doch
nicht an anderen teilen des landes zu
entblößen die nato besteht mit ihren
waffen an der grenze er weiß ganz genau
dass die nato keine bedrohung für
russland darstellt und genau deshalb
kann er sich das erlauben kann er sich
das leisten einen großen teil dieser
streitkräfte an der verkehrskreisel
strategisch und wichtigen regionen zu
ukraine einzusetzen insofern ist das für
mich eine klare wieder der these die
hier vorgetragen wird die nato sei eine
bedrohung für russland wir sind keine
bedrohungen
finnland und schweden nehmen das recht
auf freie zwar den anspruch kater 5 bis
1990 im übrigen auch nato muss kein
grund die akte die präsident jelzin
verstand mitunterzeichnet hat russland
selbst nimmt das recht auf freie und es
war immer wieder für sich in anspruch
europäische wirtschaftsunion
militärischer bandstand pakt mit anderen
staaten zentralasiens und der umgebung
das haben wir immer akzeptiert und
toleriert weil wir sagen das recht auf
freie bundesweit steht auf russland zu
aber es steht eben genauso auch schweden
finnland ukraine georgien und moldau zu
und das müssen wir auch noch mal hier an
dieser stelle deutlich sagen
auch ich sehe
mit einer gewissen sorge auf die taten
diskussion mit der türkei ich stelle
fest dass schweden und findet in keiner
weise gegen eigene verfassung oder
rechtsgrundsätze oder gegen grundsätze
der eu oder des europa hat es verstoßen
werden wenn sie jetzt ihre rechtsordnung
anpassen an das was in anderen staaten
europas zu machen bei uns blick auf
terrorismus geboten ist ich setze darauf
dass die türkei das signal dass andere
staaten schnell ratifizieren
auch sieht und erkennt und dass die
türkische regierung schnell auch diesen
entsprechenden ratifizierungs schritt
unternimmt in diesem sinne soll das
heute auch eine ermutigung an die türkei
seinen herzlichen dank
jugend mit der großen hoffnung dass
die ratifizierung durch das deutsche
parlament auch eine signalwirkung
richtung erdogan haben mag dennis grote
zu versetzen dass außer dem ausschuss
zunächst
und kollegen ja alle wissen demokratie
braucht zeit
umso begeisterter bin ich dass wir
angesichts dieser so wichtigen
entscheidung es geschafft haben
bundesregierung deutsche bundestag heute
auch der bundesrat eine entscheidung zu
treffen das macht eben auch deutlich
dass wir zu unserer verantwortung stehen
dass es auch mal richtig flott gehen
kann ohne dass demokratische prozesse in
irgendeiner weise nicht eingehalten
werden und das finde ich großartig dafür
möchte ich erstmal allen herzlich danke
sagen
zumal ich den kollegen jürgen hartmut
zustimmen kann
wenn man jetzt eingeladen wurde von der
nato und wenn man jetzt auch schon mit
im nato rat sitzen darf heißt das noch
lange nicht dass der artikel 5 die
beistands klausel schon gilt und ich
weiß dass unsere freundinnen und freunde
in schweden und in finnland auch sorgen
haben deswegen sollten wir alles dafür
tun dass diese so genannte graue zeit
des übergangs so kurz wie möglich ist
und dass wir das gleichzeitig mit einer
klaren ansage verknüpfen in richtung
schweden und in richtung finnland auch
wenn ihr formal noch nicht mitglied der
nato seit ihr könnt euch auf uns
verlassen wir stehen an eurer seite
[Applaus]
das gift der
putin schon lügenpropaganda hat sich
über viele jahre hinweg in europa und in
teilen der welt ausgebreitet leider auch
in deutschland
und wir alle kennen dieses negativ
die immer aggressiver auftreten der nato
greift immer weiter in den östlichen
raum europas vor
bemächtigt sich der einflusssphäre
russlands
ignoriert traditionen
ignoriert dass putin die russische
sicherheitsbedürfnis und stellt damit
eine gefährdung der europäischen
friedensordnung da
spätestens allerspätestens seit dem 24
februar allerspätestens seit diesem 24
februar wissen wir alle es gibt in
europa nur einen aggressor es gibt in
europa nur ein land das die friedens-
und freiheitsidee bedroht und das ist
russland und das ist putin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich weiß die kriegerischen
märchenstunden sind immer wieder auch
unterhaltsam aber sie haben meistens ein
problem sie haben meistens ein problem
das sind eben märchen und sie haben mit
der faktenlage nicht immer etwas zu tun
und ich finde ich finde ihre vorwürfe
derart abenteuerlich weil sie sich ihr
lob und ihr anerkennung gegenüber
finnland und schweden
sparen können diese beiden länder sind
ein leuchtfeuer der freiheit der
menschenrechte und der demokratie und
gelten fielen in der welt als ort der
hoffnung und der zuversicht die können
sie es wagen diesen starken zu
unterstellen sie würden internationales
oder europäisches recht schleifen weil
es ein memorandum eine vereinbarung mit
herrn erdogan gibt diese kultur des
misstrauens gegenüber unseren nordischen
freundinnen und freunden halte ich
angesichts dieses politischen krieges
für völlig inakzeptabel und für völlig
verworren und es macht auch deutlich
dass sie zu außenpolitischer
verantwortung leider nicht in der lage
sind
ja
da hat sich mal wieder herr putin selbst
ins knie geschossen er hat gedroht er
wolle die finlandia sierung europas und
was hat er bekommen da kann ich nur joe
biden den amerikanischen präsidenten
zitieren die nato sierung europas das
ist das ergebnis und ich weiß dass ich
auch hier im bundestag nicht alle mal
gleich freudig der nato zugewendet haben
und auch wir haben schmerzhafte
konsequenzen zu ziehen denn wir müssen
jetzt auch ein klares signal nicht nur
in richtung schweden und finnland aus
senden sondern in richtung unserer
mittel osteuropäischen partner die
zukunft der nato bedeutet dass es eine
stärkung der europäischen flanke der
nato gibt aber wir werden weiterhin auf
eine ganz enge transatlantische
zusammenarbeit setzen müssen weil viele
partnerinnen und partner in der eu und
in der nato nach wie vor sich eine
eigene sicherheit den eigenen free den
eigenen frieden nicht ohne die
vereinigten staaten von amerika
vorstellen können und für uns
gleichermaßen die pflicht die
sicherheitsinteressen und die friedens
interessen und die freiheits interessen
unserer mittel ost und nord europäischen
partnerinnen und partner dürfen wir
niemals wieder ignorieren wir müssen sie
in den mittelpunkt unseres eigenen
interesses stellen und das sollte unsere
lehre aus den jüngsten barbarischen
ereignissen sein und deswegen sage ich
heute liebe freundinnen und freunde
schumi willkommens wär ja wir freuen uns
auf euch vielen dank
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
rüdiger lukasiewicz
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
exzellenzen liebe kollegen mit schweden
und finnland treten zwei europäische
nationen der nato bei auf die sich
deutschland und das bündnis verlassen
können beide länder unterhalten
hochwertige streitkräfte schweden
reaktivierte
2018 die wehrpflicht finnland hat einen
reservisten chor das sogar vielen
europäischen regulären armeen überlegen
ist und ganz wichtig die kultur
dieser beiden nordländer garantiert eine
reibungslose integration ins bündnis
deutschlands sicherheit wird von dieser
erweiterung
unmittelbar profitieren wer heute der
aufnahme schwedens und finnlands in die
nato zustimmt bekennt sich zu
deutschlands sicherheit schweden und
finnland stärken die nordost flanke der
nato die letzten wochen haben allerdings
gezeigt wo die schwäche des bündnisses
liegt an der südostflanke die türkei hat
die beitrittsverhandlungen erneut dazu
genutzt um europa zu erpressen
erdogan hat damit wieder einmal mehr
bewiesen dass die türkei niemals teil
von europa sein wird
meine
meine damen und herren die nord
erweiterung bietet die chance den
europäischen pfeiler der nato endlich zu
stärken wer dies tut kann zum einen
totgeburten wie die eu armee begraben
zum anderen ist der weg hin zu einer
europäischen nato zugleich der weg zu
einer größeren unabhängigkeit
von den usa das ist für deutschland oder
europa ein ziel von immenser bedeutung
ich darf die bundesregierung daran
erinnern dass unabhängigkeit von amerika
während der tragzeit groß in mode war
sie sollten die jetzt zeigen dass diese
absicht nicht nur mit ihrer abneigung
gegen trump zu tun hatte sondern
tatsächlich strategisch begründet waren
eine europäische nato ist eine
notwendigkeit um europa aus dem
schraubstock der großmächte zu befreien
schweden und finnland können dazu
beitragen
als wir es als willkommensgeschenk
sollte die bundesregierung den vielen
worten endlich taten folgen lassen das
ziel muss sein die bundeswehr zur kampf
stärksten armee europas aufzubauen und
führung zu übernehmen
strategischer autonomie wird einem nicht
geschenkt man muss sie sich nehmen
vielen dank
der bundestag diskutiert über den
gesetzentwurf zum nato-beitritt finnland
und schweden den historiker marcus faber
war bis vor kurzem
verteidigungspolitischer sprecher der
fdp-bundestagsfraktion jetzt ist er
mitglied im verteidigungsausschuss
seit dem 24 februar weiß auch jeder wir
haben krieg mitten in europa ein
brutaler angriff von putin auf die
ukraine die friedensordnung in der wir
leben steht vor dem aus seit diesem
zeitpunkt weiß auch jeder warum viele
staaten insbesondere kleine staaten sich
verteidigungsbündnisses anschließend
gegen putin will niemand alleine
dastehen meine damen und herren dass die
ukraine überfallen wurde und nicht die
baltischen staaten liegt daran dass die
ukraine keinen schutz durch andere hat
sie steht alleine da die baltischen
staaten estland lettland litauen sind
geschützt durch die nato es ist
verständlich dass jetzt auch andere
staaten mitglied der nato werden wollen
finnland hat eine
1368 kilometer lange grenze zu russland
die bedrohung ist real
sie ist so real dass finnland und
schweden ihre neutrale haltung aufgeben
eine neue qualität die sie sogar einen
kalten krieg aufrecht erhalten haben in
finnland befürworten 75 prozent der
bevölkerung den beitritt zur nato in
schweden sind es 64 zu haben finnland
und schweden anträge gestellt und sie
werden hoffentlich in wenigen wochen
mitglied 31 und 32 in der nato werden
meine damen und herren
benannt wenn ein und stärken stärken
dadurch nicht nur ihre eigene sicherheit
sie stärken auch unsere sicherheit in
europa und in deutschland finnland und
schweden tragen dazu bei dass nordeuropa
aber insbesondere der ostseeraum
sicherer werden sie haben gute modern
ausgerüstete streitkräfte die mit der
nato gut zusammenarbeiten das haben sie
bei gemeinsamen manövern auch schon
bewiesen die sie mit der nato
durchgeführt haben die
russische föderation war bisher in der
lage die baltischen staaten leicht
abzuschneiden und einzunehmen durch den
beitritt finnlands und schwedens haben
wir jetzt eine realistische
verteidigungsfähigkeit der nato für das
gesamte bündnisgebiet auch für die
baltischen staaten und das ist glaube
ich eine wirkliche errungenschaft
meine damen und herren wir
leben zurzeit ein in europa ein konflikt
von gesellschafts modellen auf der einen
seite haben wir eine diktatur ihre
interessen mit gewalt mit krieg
durchzusetzen versucht auf der anderen
seite haben wir demokratie die sich
zusammenschließen weil sie nicht in
einer solchen diktatur leben wollen
niemand will gut dienst opfer sein meine
damen und herren das ist das schicksal
von dem wir heute mit unserem beschluss
hier finden schweden und hoffentlich
auch viele andere beraten können ein weg
der den ukrainern leider verschlossen
ist weil wir in der vergangenheit nicht
entschieden genug reagiert haben das
muss unsere lehre sein deswegen sagen
wir zwei demokraten ja zum beitritt von
finnland und schweden in die nato für
die ukraine geht das nicht da sie im
krieg ist deswegen sagen wir aber der
ukraine dass wir sie unterstützen dafür
steht die zeitenwende dieser koalition
die auch die union mit trägt dafür steht
die zeiten von olaf scholz deswegen
beliefern wir die ukraine mit waffen und
arbeiten zusammen in der nato für eine
bessere gemeinsame sicherheit meine
damen und herren sicherheit in europa
funktioniert nur gemeinsam auf der
politischen ebene arbeiten wir bereits
gut zusammen wie als verteidiger der
freien demokraten werden zum beispiel
nächsten monat im august nach finnland
reisen um dort mit unseren kolleginnen
und kollegen zu sprechen mit den
finnischen streitkräften über die
bedrohungssituation und auch über ihre
fähigkeiten zu sprechen und ich hoffe
dass wir diese gespräche demnächst auch
alle in der nato führen wenn wir heute
diesen beschluss hier so treffen ich
bedanke mich für ihre aufmerksamkeit und
bitte um die zustimmung vielen dank
auch markus faber von fdp ist immerhin
es ist eine große stärkung auch für die
nato die nächste rednerin jetzt mehrere
spieler werk von den bündnisgrünen sich
opfer und der ausschuss abrüstung
rüstungskontrolle und nichtverbreitung
geendet hat starte ich mit schwedisch
die disco parlament wird welt kommen das
wäre ja finnland und auch wenn ein
schwedisch ein wenig eingerostet ist ist
die botschaft heute dennoch klar
die botschaft ist dennoch klar der
bundestag heißt schweden und finnland
willkommen
und auch wenn er bringt der
angriffskrieg russlands ein trauriger
ist gibt dieser beitritt dennoch auch
irgendwie hoffnung dann in einer zeit in
der die internationale
sicherheitspolitik wenig anderes ist als
dunkle gewitterwolken zeigen wir heute
eben klar dass unsere werte uns eine und
dass wir an der seite unserer partner
innen an der seite unserer freund innen
stehen
inwieweit die nato militärisch
hervorragende neue bündnispartner in
gewinnt wurde bereits ausgeführt der
beitritt bringt mehr sicherheit in den
ostseeraum und stärkt die nordflanke
beide armeen sind hoch ausgebildet und
ausgestattet
und jede zeitenwende und das ist dieser
beitritt schwedens und finnlands nach
langer jahren der neutralität bringt
auch chancen für veränderungen und lebt
auch die nato zum evaluieren ein nato
wiederbelebt vom bescheinigten und schon
erwähnten gehirn tod kann durch die
aufgekündigte sicherheits ordnung in
europa ihre eigene krise überwinden
und was schweden und finnland gerade
auch dafür mitbringen ist ein
zeitgemäßes ein zeitgerechtes
verständnis von außen und
sicherheitspolitik vom
verteidigungspolitik
findungs kooperation trudel der
umfassende sicherheit hat schon lange
den gedanken verinnerlicht dass
gesellschaftliche
gesamtgesellschaftliche sicherheit auf
enger zusammenarbeit zwischen politik
zwischen zivilgesellschaft wirtschaft
und bürger innen beruht und mit schweden
gewinnen wir auch das hat die kollegin
bürger schon erwähnt die vorreiterin für
feministische aussenpolitik die rolle
die schweden im kampf für eine
geschlechtergerechte außen und
sicherheitspolitik aber auch für
abrüstung und rüstungskontrolle
eingenommen hat es bis mir ist merkens
wert wie wir sind beide staaten
beobachterinnen bei der
vertragsstaatenkonferenz des atomwaffen
verbots vertrages auch das wird in der
zukunft ein weiterhin eine wichtige
rolle spielen und dessen perspektiven
die in der aktuellen situation nicht aus
den augen verlieren dürfen denn eine
residente außen und sicherheitspolitik
ist eine politik die der komplexität der
realität entspricht und sie nicht
vereinfacht und in einer zeit von
wachsende nordsee tourismus und
angriffen auf die freiheit auch
innerhalb der allianz ist es hilfreich
die bündnisverteidigung mit mehr als nur
einem militärischen hammer anzugehen
treten wir also gemeinsam für unsere
werte und sicherheit ein und
ratifizieren wir den beitritt unserer
freundinnen schweden und finden
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
florian hahn
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir haben es heute schon mehrfach gehört
es ist wahrhaft ein großer historischer
moment und gleichzeitig ausdruck der
unmittelbaren bedrohung europas und
russland ein historischer moment und
dieser
hinweis sei gestattet an dem der
bundeskanzler leider nicht teilnehmen
der beitritt von schweden und finnland
ist ein starkes und wichtiges signal der
stärkung des bündnisses wir freuen uns
auf zwei potente und leistungsfähige
partner in der nato
es ist aber auch ein trauriger tag denn
es tobt weiterhin ein furchtbarer krieg
in europa der finnland und schweden ihre
tiefsten überzeugungen ändern ließ aus
konkreter furcht vor einem skrupellosen
nachbarn
und sie ist so groß geworden diese
furcht dass beispielsweise schweden nach
200 jahren seine neutralität aufgibt und
kolleginnen und kollegen diese furcht
ist nicht nur historisch bedingt sondern
sie ist unmittelbar denn unsere freunde
in skandinavien unsere freunde im
baltikum unsere freundinnen polen sind
zutiefst davon überzeugt dass bei einer
niederlage der ukraine sie unmittelbar
in das visier putins fallen werden und
er auch dort zuschlagen möchte um sein
werk die wiederherstellung der einfluss
wäre der alten sowjetunion fortzusetzen
und ich teile diese einschätzung wie
vermutlich die meisten aber wenn das
wirklich so ist dann geht es doch bei
der unterstützung der ukraine nicht nur
um die freiheit eines souveränen eines
demokratischen und eines europäischen
landes sondern dann geht es in diesem
konflikt auch um unsere freiheit und
unsere sicherheit und wenn das auch
und wenn es auch um unsere sicherheit
und unsere freiheit geht dann müssen wir
doch alles tun ohne kriegspartei zu
werden dann mit putin diesen von ihm die
zettelten grausamen krieg verliert und
die ukraine diesen krieg gewinnt
kolleginnen und kollegen
und ich sage ganz klar
und ich sage ganz klar deutschland tut
hier zu wenig allen ankündigungen zum
trotz die bundesregierung tut zu wenig
wir könnten viel mehr tun erstes
beispiel transportpanzer fuchs
richtigerweise von teilen der grünen und
von teilen der fdp gefordert wir haben
uns dieser idee angeschlossen gestern
hat die ampel hier im parlament dagegen
gestimmt die ministerin hat das
begründet mit dem argument die
lieferungen würde die bundeswehr
ausplündern und unsere
verteidigungsfähigkeit gefährden das ist
doch lächerlich kolleginnen und kollegen
genauso lächerlich ist es das zweite
thema schützenpanzer marder herr
bundeskanzler scholz frau ministerin
lamprecht denken sie ernsthaft dass es
für putin einen unterschied macht ob wir
einen fleck panzer gepard oder einen
schützenpanzer marder liefern vor allem
nachdem wir bereits die panzerhaubitze
geliefert haben denken sie wirklich dass
putin einen unterschied macht ob ein
panzer nur in die luft schießt wie sie
es uns verkauft worden stichwort
dauerfeuer nein das tut man nicht das
ist doch alles lächerlich kolleginnen
und kollegen
drittes beispiel
der bundeskanzler hat im deutschen
bundestag hier angekündigt der ukraine
flugabwehrsysteme vom typ iris t zu
liefern genauer gesagt genau ein system
zu liefern und zwar nicht aus der aus
bundeswehrbeständen sondern direkt von
der industrie der ukrainische
verteidigungsminister hat aber unserer
fraktion gegenüber in kiew erklärt dass
die ukraine zehnmal so viele systeme
benötigt und bereits angefragt hat herr
bundeskanzler liebe bundesregierung
wieso wollen sie dann nur ein system
genehmigen das doch alles nicht mehr zu
verstehen kolleginnen und kollegen
die bundesregierung
die bundesregierung könnte viel mehr tun
kolleginnen und kollegen ohne dabei
kriegspartei zu werden ohne dabei die
verteidigungsfähigkeit unseres landes zu
gefährden und ohne unsere partner zum
riskieren und ich fordere die
bundesregierung auf endlich das zu tun
geben sie endlich grünes licht für diese
für die ukraine und existenzielle
unterstützung eine unterstützung wie
auch unsere sicherheit unmittelbar die
und herzlichen dank
florian hahn war das der
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
ralf stegner jetzt ob man im
unterausschuss für die spd
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kollegen den kollegen exzellenzen dass
unsere nordischen freunde finden und
schweden jetzt so schnell der nato
beitreten kann mit dem
völkerrechtswidrigen russischen
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine einen
tragischen anlass dieser krieg mitten in
europa ist in der tat eine zeitenwende
und dennoch ist ein sehr willkommener
schritt das mit finnland und schweden 2
gefestigt und fortschrittlichen
demokratie und verlässliche europäische
partner unser transatlantisches bündnis
verstärkt es liegt angesichts der
geopolitischen militärischen bedrohungen
die von putins russland ausgeht im
sicherheitsinteresse dieser beiden
länder teil der nato zu sein und deshalb
haben beide staaten ihre jahrzehntelange
politik geändert aber viel mehr noch ist
ein großer gewinn eine große stärken für
uns und für die nato natürlich spielt
bei diesem schritt strategisch die
geografie eine große rolle und beide
länder haben modernen und höchst
professionelle armeen die die
fähigkeiten der nato mitgliedstaaten
sehr gut ergänzen aber finden schweden
teilen vor allem in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik und zur europäischen
unsere humanitären friedens und
abrüstungspolitischen werte und sie
werden diese position innerhalb der
nadel durchsetzungsfähiger machen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren und man
muss es so deutlich sagen ich verzichte
auf die details des abkommens finnland
und schweden stehen unseren prioritäten
und ich unseren strategischen zielen
näher als manch andere der bereits teil
der nato ist die wir kolleginnen
kollegen ich bin als sozialdemokrat
besonders froh dass mit schweden und
finden dann auch zwei staaten mit
starker friedens politischer tradition
mitglied der nato werden zwei staaten
die teil der job initiative sind die die
atomare abrüstung voranbringen und den
atomwaffensperrvertrag stärken wollen
zwei staaten die als beobachter am
ersten vertragsstaatenkonferenz in
atomen verbots vertrag in wien
teilgenommen haben wie es die ampel
koalition auch für deutschland
beschlossen hat trotz der
fraktionsübergreifenden freundin
einigkeit will ich aber mit blick auf
das was der kollege hahn gesagt hat ich
habe sonst darauf verzichtet eine
nebenbemerkung schon machen herr
oppositionsführer ich verdanke ihnen
zwar die wertvolle erfahrungen des
ersten sprungs in diesem hause aber es
war schon etwas schwer den finnischen
der finnischen botschafterin der
schwedischen geschäftsträgerin die zu
gast bei der feierlichen sondersitzung
des auswärtigen ausschusses waren zu
erklären warum wir plötzlich rüber
kommen müssen und warum sie warum sie
hier parteipolitischen klamauk
veranstalten während der bundeskanzlerin
die ausfahrt ausgemacht da ist die höhe
unterschiedlicher oppositionsführer ganz
unterschiedlich ganz runter schließlich
lud das will ich ihnen sagen wir kümmern
uns um internationale herausforderung
sie machen kleinen partei politischen
klamauk tester unterschied meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren lassen sie
mich aber weil ich finde wir sollten im
wesentlichen darauf verzichten über
solche sachen zu reden zu lassen sie
haben angefangen lassen sie mich eine
persönliche anmerkung es kommen zwei
nachbarn und freunde die nato das freut
mich besonders als abgeordneter aus
schleswig holstein ich habe jahrelang
aus meinem büro in kiel awp die oc
geschaut auch der es eben nicht nur für
verbindung nach dänemark und norwegen
sondern auch nach finnland und schweden
gibt es das sind nachbarn und freunde
sind uns sehr willkommen ist toll dass
sie da sind sehr geehrte vertretern den
ausländern
bereits gestern sagen brecht und meine
lieben amberg kolleginnen kollegen und
auch die damen und herren von der
opposition weitgehend haben dargelegt
warum es für diesen antrag eine große
mehr in diesem hause gibt gerade mit dem
beitritt von finnland und schweden wird
besonders deutlich dass die nato
verteidigungsbündnis ist und immer
bleiben muss und eben nicht aggressive
pläne gegen andere verfolgt mit diesem
neuen mitglieder sind wir in unserem
verteidigungsbündnis besser aufgestellt
für eine stabile transatlantische und
europäische sicherheitsarchitektur die
beständig verbessert wird deshalb ist es
gut und wichtig dass wir diesen schritt
heute so schnell und mit so großer
mehrheit vollziehen ist ein guter tag
für die sicherheit wo ist ein guter tag
für die neue friedensordnung in europa
viel näher sind
nächster redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
henning otte
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
exzellenzen meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren geschichte live miterlebt
heute die beiden souveränen europäischen
staaten finnland und schweden beantragt
den beitritt zur nato die cdu/csu
begrüßen diesen beitritt und wir werden
zustimmen im deutschen bundestag und
auch im bundesrat heute zeitgleich es
wäre eine gute geste gewesen wenn schon
der begriff historie bemüht wird dass
der bundeskanzler oder viel leichter
herr vizekanzler oder vielleicht auch
sein stellvertreter heute hier gesicht
gezeigt hätten die nato meine damen und
herren ist der garant für frieden und
freiheit einer für alle und alle für
einen
dieser beitrag beider länder dieser
beitritt ist eine militärische stärkung
und sichert den ostseeraum zukünftig
noch besser ab durch den angriffskrieg
putins müssen wir leider feststellen
europe business europe is on wall und
wir begrüßen die reaktion eines
strategischen konzeptes der nato jetzt
geht es den sicherheitspolitischen deich
an der osteuropäischen flanke
signifikant zu erhöhen denn nach artikel
5 stehen wir alle füreinander ein den
nächsten auch mit finnland und mit
schweden und auch für finnland und für
schweden und das ist eine gute situation
meine damen und herren
für die bundesregierung geht es jetzt
auch die hausaufgaben zu erfüllen und
die zusagen an die nato zu erfüllen und
signifikant auf in die verteidigung zu
investieren das 100 milliarden programm
ist ein richtiger schritt in die
richtige richtung und wir als cdu csu
haben durchgesetzt dass dieses geld darf
ausschließlich bei der bundeswehr
ankommt geld was allerdings nicht aus
dem laufenden haushalt kommt sondern
geld was durch eine schuldenaufnahme
realisiert wird zusätzlich zu einer
ohnehin schon der rekord netto
kreditaufnahme
hier wird deutlich dass die ampel
regierung nicht bereit ist eine
priorisierung auch für die verteidigung
vorzusehen es ist doch offenkundig dass
wenn mehr beschafft wird auch mehr
betriebsausgaben prekär
generiert werden und wenn wir
feststellen dass der entwurf für den
haushaltsplan 2023 offensichtlich sogar
noch eine senkung vorsieht dann ist das
ein anzeichen für eine wende aus der
zeitenwende meine damen und herren
deutschland muss bereit sein mehr
führung zu übernehmen
deswegen ist es gut dass wir im baltikum
in ernst fordert präsenz weiter stärken
und auch im nächsten jahr bereit sind
als deutschland die schnelle speerspitze
die wtf zu übernehmen aber es wird
versäumt politische sichtbare
initiativen auch in europa wahrzunehmen
warum frau bundesministerin der
verteidigung sind sie nicht längst viel
mehr unterwegs um die europäische säule
innerhalb der nato auch zu stärken und
hier die verteidigungs union weiter
voranzubringen
meine damen und herren putins
angriffskrieg und putins reaktion zeigt
unsere demokratie muss nach innen und
nach außen gestärkt werden wir müssen
bereit sein mehr in die sicherheit
unseres landes zu investieren die
resilienz auch zu erhöhen die kampf der
bundeswehr musikant erhöht werden die
sicherheitsarchitektur muss neu
aufgestellt werden das silodenken der
bundesministerien sollte aufgegeben
werden zugunsten eines nationalen
sicherheitsrates nun endlich ist es auch
allen wenn auch durch den angriffskrieg
deutlich geworden den letzten skeptikern
und kritikern der nato die nato ist
unser garant und wir müssen unsere
verpflichtungen erfüllen es ist gut dass
in der spd ein gesehen worden ist dass
die putin kompanie falsch war und es ist
gut dass die ausrüstungs rhetorik der
grünen eingesehen nicht zielführend ist
aber vor allem ist auch deutlich
geworden dass die verbrüderung der
linken mit moskau herr gysi gescheitert
ist und die nationale anbahnungen
anlehnung der afg an russland meine
damen und herren wir als cdu csu von der
wir als cdu csu wir haben als partei der
bundeswehr stets für die stärkung der
bundeswehr gewirkt denn fliegen erwächst
aus stärke der beitritt finnlands und
schwedens ist eine stärkung ein
herzliches willkommen beider länder in
der nato wir stehen gemeinsam ein für
frieden und freiheit herzlichen dank
henning otte war der letzte redner in
dieser debatte
ich schließe die aussprache bevor wir
zur
zur abstimmung kommen taten zwei
abgeordnete den wunsch geäußert eine
persönliche erklärung nach § 31 unserer
geschäftsordnung abzugeben ich gebe
zuerst das wort zu einer persönlichen
erklärung vor der abstimmung aus der fdp
fraktion im abgeordnetenhaus vahle
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
sehr geehrte damen und herren es ist ein
sehr demokratisches recht dass man so
ein abweichendes votum in einem
parlament
in einem rechtsstaat auch
vertreten kann und
deswegen
sage ich ihnen
ich habe genau die argumente
die kollege gauland hier vorgetragen hat
für mich abgewogen
und ich habe auch alle argumente der
krise die wir alle kennen
vorgetragen hat auch persönlich für mich
abgewogen denn hier steht folgende
entscheidungen im raum
womit werden finnland und schweden die
ich als demokratische staaten sehr hoch
achter womit werden sie in zukunft
besser fahren das müssen sie selbst
entscheiden die neutralität die sie über
viele jahrzehnte bei gehalten haben hat
sie bisher vor allem beschützt
und es ist nicht allein die militärische
stärke die man in die waagschale wirft
die militärische konflikte vermeiden
hilft es ist mal sogar viel wichtiger
eine stabile und solide friedensordnung
und diese wiederherzustellen und das ist
nicht nur frage in erster linie von
militärgewalt sondern von verhandlungen
und beim einem abwägungsprozess das sage
ich auch zu meinem kollegen bin ich zu
der meinung gekommen
nicht aus pragmatischen gründen ihren
etwas für gut oder falsch zu halten
sondern ich bin zu der entscheidung
gekommen dass ich heute
für diesen beitritt dieses
beitrittsgesuch nicht meine stimme geben
werde in abweichung von der fast nahezu
gesamten fdp fraktion die sich dafür
entschieden hat
zweitens möchte ich ihnen sagen in der
aktuellen situation
kommen sie erst zum schluss sie hatten
nur zeit zweimal 0
22 nun machen sie noch ein zwei sätze
dann war ich noch eins versetzte das
reicht mir um das klar zu machen
europa braucht eine starke
sicherheitsarchitektur es muss schluss
gemacht werden mit der unsäglichen
kriegsrhetorik die mittlerweile in
unseren zeitung stattfindet es muss ein
weg gefunden werden denn ein frieden in
europa wird langfristig nur mit
einbeziehung von russland
und am stopp der ost erweiterung kommen
wir brauchen nicht 300.000 soldaten
statt 40 an der sogenannten ostflanke
wir wollen nie wieder einen krieg in
europa leben nie wieder krieg kommen sie
bin ich auch irgendwelche gang vielen
dank ihre erklärung haben wir gehört das
nächste mitglied aus der art der
fraktion hat das wort auch für zwei
minuten für eine persönliche erklärung
dr christine baum
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
sehr geehrte gäste ich habe großes
verständnis für die sicherheitsbedürfnis
wird das sicherheitsbedürfnis der
findung und schweden und dennoch muss
uns allen bewusst sein dass dieser
beitritt eine provokation für russland
darstellt
und zirkus und zur ausbreitung des
krieges führen kann daran kann keinen
von uns gelegen sagen ich denke darin
sind wir uns alle einig in der aktuellen
situation wollen also eine ausbreitung
des krieges in der aktuellen situation
muss deshalb jede eskalation vermieden
werden wir sind alle in frieden
aufgewachsen und ich glaube nur wenige
können sich überhaupt vorstellen was
krieg bedeutet
schon heute gibt es viel zu viele
unschuldige opfer schon heute gibt es
viel zu viel leid schmerz und tränen und
deshalb muss der krieg schnellstmöglich
beendet werden das muss unser aller ziel
sein und das geht nur über verhandlungen
kompromisse und aufeinander zugehen
auf einem weg zum frieden
stellt meiner meinung nach die aufnahme
der beiden länder heute der falsche weg
da den frieden das anstreben von frieden
unser erster priorität sein und deshalb
stimme ist dagegen denn bei allem was
wir tun
bei allem was wir tun müssen wir immer
auch das ende bedenken vielen dank
so liebe kolleginnen kollegen wir kommen
jetzt zur abstimmung über den von den
fraktionen der spd cdu/csu bündnis
90/die grünen und fdp eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zu den protokollen zum
nordatlantik vertrag über den beitritt
der republik finnland und des
königsreichs schweben der auswärtige
ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache
2652 den gesetzentwurf der fraktionen
spd cdu csu bündnis 90/die grünen und
fdp auf drucksache
2534 anzunehmen ich bitte diejenigen die
den gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich
zu erheben
das sind die fraktionen der spd
ich hab das ich habe das aufgekommen der
spd bündnis 90 die grünen fdp cdu csu
fraktion und die afg fraktion wer stimmt
dagegen
das ist die fraktion die linke und die
beiden abgeordneten vahle und dr baum
enthaltungen
zwei enthaltungen der kollegen aus der
fraktion
damit ist der gesetzentwurf angenommen
ja meine damen und herren der bundestag
hat den nato-beitritt wunsch von
finnland und schweden hier soeben
abgesegnet standing ovations jetzt
zunächst von unions fraktion jetzt steht
auch fest dass reste haus aus
auch die regierungsbank nur die fdp
bleibt im sitzen man applaudiert in
richtung der beiden vertreterinnen der
beiden länder die sichtlich gerührt sind
deutschland ist der erste nato staat von
30 der jetzt hier dieses beitrags gesund
ratifiziert hat jetzt war ich selber ein
bisschen zu schnell natürlich muss der
bundesrat gleich erst noch zustimmen
aber daran gibt es wohl keinen zweifel
das votum des bundestages wird jetzt
weiter geleitet in die länderkammer und
der bundesrat hat heute ein vielfältiges
programm mit sehr vielen abstimmung die
auch wichtig sind damit gesetz in kraft
treten können und das ist ein punkt über
den wir sie gleich bericht unterrichten
wollen